on va évoquer l'une des affaires les
plus terribles euh horribles de toute
l'histoire de TPMP on va recevoir dans
un instant Benjamin il y a 3 ans cet
homme découvre le pire dans sa maison il
va nous raconter l'histoire elle est
folle il y a 3 semaines le procès s'est
tenu euh on va pas tout vous dire parce
que si je lis les fiches et ben
l'histoire vous l'avez et j'espère que
dans le récap ils vont pas vous raconter
toute l'histoire puisqu'il va être avec
nous dans un instant pas grave merci
regardez en novembre 2020 à Lausanne un
jeune père de famille assiste à une
scène d'horreur en découvrant Estelle sa
fille de 3 ans dans une mar de sang la
mère de famille a reconnu lesffit c'est
elle qui aurait poignardé à mort sa
fille mais alors que 3 ans après ce
drame la femme qui a tué sa fille de 354
coups de ciseau vient d'être reconnu
irresponsable de ses actes par la
chambre d'instruction la mère d'Estelle
ne sera pas jugée le père d'Estelle se
dit aujourd'hui anéanti je suis dévasté
dépité révolté la justice n'a pas
respecté ma fille le cri du cœur de
Benjamin papa d''estelle ce soir dans
TPMP merci Benjamin d'être avec nous
merci beaucoup euh cette histoire c'est
une des histoires les plus fortes euh
voilà qu'on est connu sur touche pas mon
poste il est 20h57 on est en direct euh
c'est avec force et courage que vous
acceptez de témoigner ce soir en direct
à la télévision il vous arrivé une des
pires choses qui puissent arriver au
cours d'une vie perdre un enfant et la
MA la manière dont vous avez perdu votre
fille et dramatique euh quel âge avait
votre fille 3 ans c'est ça ouais elle
avait 3 ans ouais H 3 ans euh elle
s'appelait comment Estelle Estelle tout
allait bien dans votre vie tout allait
bien euh vous ê avec la maman depuis
combien de temps ça faisait 12 ans qu'on
était ensemble vraiment le bonheur une
rencontre standard le
bonheur on a profité de la vie enfin une
vie normale quoi avec Sandra avec Sandra
avec Sandra Lodi c'est ça étiez vous
étiez vous étiez très amoureux très lié
très enfin une belle une belle famille
j'ai rencontré une femme douce sensible
qui m'a charmé je su tombé amoureux
d'elle on a pris le temps de vous êtes
connu comment on s'est connu via des
amis qui nous ont lors d'une soirée qui
nous ont présenté on a échangé des mots
s bien passé on a bien rigolé on s'est
revu et on est sorti ensemble d'une
manière classique quoi bien sûr et après
donc là vous êtes resté 12 ans ensemble
exactement ouais vous étiez marié non
non on est en union libre en couple
d'accord vous avez donc
Estelle ça se passe bien au moment de la
naissance d''estelle ouais cé un choix
commun de fonder une famille d'avoir une
fille la naissance d'Estelle on est ravi
c'est le moment de bonheur qu on on
démarre la vie de famille tout se passe
bien on s'occupe chacun tous les deux
des
Stell et et on commence à construire une
vie standard quoi vous étiez heureux on
était heureux ouais rrouvz votre petite
fille tous les tous les soirs vous
faites quoi dans la vie je suis menusier
ouais d'accord euh mais
il y a des tensions qui ont fait que
vous soutiez vous souhaitiez mettre fin
à la relation si c'est pas trop
indiscret pourquoi qu'est-ce qui se
passait à la naissance de notre fille
Sandra c'est elle s'est centrée sur elle
c'est
devenu qu'elle était jalouse aussi elle
était jalouse possessive même vis-à-vis
de moi c'est ce que j'ai expliqué voilà
dès que je parlais à une femme ou que
j'avais une amie trop proche que je
l'appelais trop souvent elle était
jalouse faisait des remonran et tout ce
que je disais ça va un petit côté
flatteur aussi d'avoir une femme qui
tient à soi je le voyais pas d'une
manière extrême et non plus comme un
défaut trop important euh mais ce côté
possessif il s'est accentué au fil du
temps avec notre fille c'est devenu son
seul centre d'intérêt moi-même j'avais
plus de place ouis j'ai perdu ma place
de père et Sandra était exclusivement
centré sur elle votre place de père et
votre place aussi de j'ai perdu ma place
de de conjointre dans un premier temps
voilà c'est ça d'abord elle voulait
s'occuper exclusivement de votre fille
et elle vous excluit de l'éducation
c'est ça exactement ouais h alors
pourquoi elle vous laissait pas vous
occuper elle disait c'est ça y est
c'était son son son alors au début je
m'en occupais les 6 premiers mois je m'
je m'en suis occupé après j'ai repris le
boulot je me suis centré sur mon boulot
d'un côté j'étais content qu'elle s'en
occupe qu'elle donne les biberons euh et
et Sandra a arrêté de travailler pour
s'occuper de notre fille
euh et du coup je men suis occupé de
moins en moins euh et j jusqu'à plus
m'en occuper du tout dès que je voulais
lui donner un biberon faire une couche
je le faisais pas bien je faisais pas
comme il faut euh elle elle m'a
complètement évincé de mon rôle de père
au fil du temps quoi alors
euh vous vous séparez h c'est vous qui
décidez de vous séparer vous lui dites
ouais c'est elle avait quel âge Estelle
quand vous êtes séparé quand on s'est
séparé elle avait 3 ans 3 ans donc
c'était voà ouais euh vous séparez vous
lui dites quoi vous lui dites il faut
qu'on on se sépare euh quand en fait
j'avais plus mon rôle de conjoint et
quand euh je lui je me suis aperçu mon
rôle de père il s'ffritait je dit que
cétait plus possible quoi vous préfériez
en fait avoir une garde partagée comme
ça quand vous avez la vous en occupez
c'était plus c'était plus c'était mieux
d'avoir limite votre fille de jours par
semaine plutôt que tous les jours et de
l'avoir pas pas laavoir du tout en fait
c'est ça ouais c'est ça ouais
je je lu demandé la la la garde alternée
et pour elle c'était inacceptable
elle a jamais envisagé
de de de se séparer de sa fille donc
donc comment vous faisz pour votre fille
comment vous faisiez comment pour voir
votre fille je la voyais mais je pouvais
je pouvais pas passer non j'avais plus
de moments seul avec elle en fait comme
elle travaillait plus dès que moi
j'étais à la maison elle était là et
pour moi voilà dès qu'on allait se
promener Sandra était toujours là et
c'est au fil du temps et c'est que tard
où où moi je je lui ai exprimé et je me
suis entre guillemets révolté contre
elle tard en lui disant mais il faut
aussi que moi j'ai des moments seul avec
elle que je puisse aller me promener
seul avec elle et euh quand tu disais ça
si si je voulais faire une activité avec
elle il fallait qu'on en arrive à la
dispute alors vous faisz chambre à pas
ouais c'est ça
et c'est le 12 novembre
2020 chez vous au nord de Lyon que le
pire arrive incroyable puisque on vous a
raconté le début de l'histoire donc un
couple tout à fait normal qui se
rencontre ils ont une petite fille
qu'ils aiment passionnément ils ont une
ça se passe très bien et puis bon après
voilà il y a des problèmes dans le
couple ça peut arriver après la
naissance d'un enfant tout ça c'est
assez classique enfin ça arrive quoi et
voilà vous faites chambre à part
peut-être qu'après on s'est dit parfois
il y a des couples qui qui reprennent et
qui
repartent mieux qu'avant mais vous le 12
novembre 2020 vous entendez votre fille
pleurer en pleine nuit parce que vous
faites chambre à part vous entendez
votre fille pleurer
vraiment et elle elle hurle non elle
pleure il arrivait qu'elle pleure
la nuit parce que je pense que c'est les
toutes les tensions qu'on avait on
s'était promis on essayait de plus
disputer devant elle enfin je pense que
c'est les disputes qui troublait ces
nuits et il arrivait souvent qu'elle
pleure la nuit cette nuit-là je l'ai
entendu et comme si sa mère qui s'en
occupait et et je suis pas monté la voir
je me suis dit elle va s'en occuper pas
allé parce que vous êtes dit sa maman va
s'en occuper ouais et je me suis
rendormi comme toutes les nuits et là
elle pleurait plus vous n'entendez plus
rien sinement ouais le lendemain matin
euh vous préparez pour aller au travail
voulez voir votre fille et là euh c'est
l'horreur le matin je me réveille comme
d'habitude je monte les marches euh
j'entends murmurer dans la chambre
d'Estelle j'entends que mon ex-conjointe
qui parle et je me dis comment ça se
fait qu'elle parle toute seule euh donc
je décide de monter voir euh et là
j'entre dans la chambre de ma fille et
je découvre ma fille sur son lit avec
mon ex conjoint de penscher sur elle et
là
euh et je je vois les les je vois le le
sang tous les impacts votre femme tue
votre fille Estelle âgé de 3 ans de plus
de 354 coups de
couteau avec un ciseau cétait avec de un
ciseau oui donc près de 50 au niveau de
la nuque ouais ça s'est passé donc dans
la nuit
h j'imagine quand vous voyez quand vous
revoyez la scène c'est c'est je vous
vois c'est c'est c'est c'est
insoutenable c'est les images que j'ai
vu j'ai été transpercé de peur j'étais
engourdi j'ai j'ai pas tout de suite
compris ce qui s'est passé ah vous voyez
votre F son j'ai vu tous ces impacts
j'ai vu une tache de sang derrière sa
tête
j'ai je comprenais pas je tremblais
et glacer le sang je sais exactement ce
que c'est physiquement j'ai ressenti
aujourd'hui mais oui c'est ça c'est
comment on doit do se sentir on doit
plus tenir sur sures sur ses jambes je
vous faites quoi à ce moment-là parce
que on a on se dit vous trouvez votre
femme euh elle elle elle l'aurait tué
dans dans dans la nuit he quand vous
l'avez entendu pleurer c'est ça ouais et
donc là c'est le matin elle est toujours
penchée sur elle alors que votre fille
est en 100 354 coup de ciseau euh vous
faites quoi vous dites quoi je je dis
qu'est-ce qui se passe euh je comprenais
pas et là elle m'a pas répondu euh enfin
s'est tourné vers moi elle m'a dit c'est
toi qui a fait ça tu as voulu nous
séparer là qu'est-ce que vous répondez à
ça j'ai rien répondu j'avais mon
téléphone dans les mains je voulais
appeler les pompiers et je tremblais
tellement que j'y suis pas arrivé donc
j'ai vou sentez de récupérer votre fille
de voir Saver là je me suis dit il faut
que je la sauve j'avais qu'une qu'une
idée en tête c'était de la sauver et
j'ai pas vu la transition entre le
moment où il était allongé dans son lit
et au momentù j'ai baissé la tête pour
taper sur mon téléphone je j'ai relevé
les yeux elle l'avait serré contre elle
comme ça ça
et je me suis dit il faut que je la
sauve faut que je la récupère pour
appeler les pompiers et la sauver quoi
j'essaie de récupérer Stelle je commence
à à tirer mais elle a tellement d'impact
je me dis que si je tire trop fort je
vais je vais vous allez avoir un je vais
l'abîmer du coup je commence à je
commence à lui taper sur la tête je me
dis il faut que je la somomme il faut
qu'elle lâche quoi donc je commence à
lui mettre des coups de points dans la
tête et j'arrive pas à laassommer
elleelle un velle avec son bras tout
j'arrive à lui faire lâcher son bras son
bras repasse devant moi je la mors je
casse son bras avec mes
dents et je prends appuit avec mon pied
sur sa tête et là je tire fort Estelle
et et je cours jusqu'à chez mes voisin
c'est ça vous vous enfermez chez votre
voisin vous avez votre fille dans les
bras et secours arrive que se passe-t-il
les secours arrive
euh enfin avant ça il y a eu des trucs
mais enfin je suis pas arrivé à faire le
massage cardiaque c'est Nico qui l'a
fait c'était très compliqué et tout
votre voisin mon voisin ouais et du coup
les les secours arrivent il y a le SAMU
mais à ce moment-là je reprends espoir
je me dis il faut qu'il la sauve et tout
et quand il branche le le monitoring ou
le et là je reprends espoir et tout
parce que j'ai j'ai l'impression qu'il y
a comme son cœur qui bat et malgré les
doutes et la vision d'horreur et tout je
me dis [__] elle viit encore et tout
faut qu'il la sauve quoi
et et malgré tout ça voilà un moment
s'arrête et il m'annonce que c'est
terminé quoi votre maison est placée
ensuite sous cé vous vous retrouvez à
l'hôpital nu c'est ça euh je ouais donc
à la suite à la suite du du l'essès moi
je suis emmené je suis emmené dans les
camions de pompiers je suis à l'hôpital
les gendarmes j'étais en cçon et en
T-shirt je me levais il récupère mon
t-shirt mon calçon il le mettent dans
des pièces à conviction donc je me
retrouveen en tenue en chambre d'hôpital
quoi en tunique d'hôpital et euh et par
la suite donc j'ai j'ai j'avais plus de
téléphone euh plus de portefeuille plus
de voiture plus de maison je me suis
retrouvé au sens propre à poil alors
ensuite euh votre votre excompagne
Sandra a avoué son meurtre HM à 6h45
elle avait créé un SMS à sa mère elle
lui avait dit J'ai tué ma fille il a
voulu la garde totale je ne peux vivre
sans elle
euh comment elle avoué son meurtre à
part par ce ce sms elle a al elle a fait
ce SMS dans un premier temps ensuite
quand je suis arrivé dans la chambre la
phrase qu'elle m'a dit tu as voulu nous
séparer c'est toi qui a fait ça tu as
voulu nous séparer les pompiers et les
gendarmes sont arrivés sa déclaration ça
été de dire j'ai réfléchi toute la nuit
il voulait me l'enlever j'étais obligé
de le
faire est-ce qu'elle lui avait déjà levé
la main dessus ça a toujours été une
femme douce sensible attentionné il y a
aucun signe euh
elle l'a jamais frappé elle a jamais eu
un mot difficile pour elle elle était
très attentionnée et elle laissait
personne s'en occuper à part elle parce
qu'elle voulait que tout soit bien fait
tout bien cadré quoi il y avait que sa
mère moi-même j'ai été exclu au fil du
temps il y avait plus que sa mère qui
avait le droit de s'en occuper quoi